[Music]
joining us now preview of Tuesday's
important elections six days away US
Senate candidate from the great state of
Arizona Congresswoman martha mcsalley US
Senate candidate from Michigan John
James is back with us US Senate
candidate from Tennessee congresswoman
Marsha Blackburn good to see you all
Martha I'm looking at your race and then
one poll has you tied at one pause
you're up and I'm thinking how is it
possible that a woman that says
Arizona's the meth-lab of democracy and
says people Arizona are crazy invites
the blind shakes lawyer the radical
lawyer to speak at Arizona State
University and says that it's okay for
Americans to join the Taliban while you
have served 28 years six tours of duty
while she was out organizing protesters
and I'm not making it up with witches
how is this even a race with the people
Arizona well Sean it is unbelievable and
this just goes to show you that she's
Chuck Schumer's top recruit and with a
lot of money with TV ads millions and
millions of dollars she's been able to
fool a lot of people they're not aware
of those things unless they're watching
your show which I'm grateful that you
keep bringing it up but the Arizona
media has been protecting her and so
she's coming across as something she's
not in the biggest political makeover in
our history but look we're down to the
wire with six days to go and we can make
sure we secure this victory with support
from people all over Arizona and the
country they can go to mcsalley for
senate comm they can contribute so we
can make sure we win and we need if
you're in Arizona look I'm asking for
your vote and I'm asking you to send out
an email do a Facebook post make sure
you get to the polls tell your friends
and family this is so high stakes and
every vote is really gonna matter I
think you're right and on every front
john james you have now closed the gap
sixteen points you got a race now in
michigan which you know what as I said
to you I I I'm I get so depressed every
time I've had you on radio or TV but
every campaign is the same the Democrats
your opponent is basically Chuck Schumer
in Michigan as are all the Democrats but
not gonna talk about the agenda they'll
never support a president's Supreme
Court justice they want to raise they
want the crumbs back they want open
borders sanctuary cities it's you know
they want Obama care how can be
Democrats be running on the biggest mess
they ever created
well Democrats have to run on identity
politics because they have no identity
they have to pit Americans against each
other in order to keep themselves
propped up and that's a different
message than I have I don't have a black
or white message I have a red and I have
a red white and blue message I am a
combat veteran who understands how to
bring people together I'm a business
leader who understands how to grow
businesses and grow Economic Opportunity
we have energy all over the state and
yeah we close the gap from 23 down to 6
down just this past Friday we have the
momentum in this race because people
recognize that we can finally have
experienced combat experience and
business experience to lead us forward
into the future you can learn more about
our race on John James for Senate comm
and the vice-president came to visit
just a little bit earlier this week and
saw the energy that we have in this race
and the momentum that we have and the
President of the United States on the
Ingraham angle a couple nights ago said
that he'd be willing to come to the
State will mr. president if you're
watching please come to Michigan we need
you to help us come across the hump and
you have excellent luck on Election Day
Eve we love to have you thank you you
are everything we want in government
with business experience military
service Marshall we've been friends a
long time I've watched your campaign one
thing there's a lot v project Veritas
tapes have come out what your tape of
governor Bredesen hiding who he really
is purposely lying to the people of
Tennessee and his staff which it turned
out being a staff actually referring to
the people of Tennessee as ignorant
I think Tennessee's one of the greatest
states in this country and I love
Nashville and country music so since
that time it seems like your poll
numbers have gone up a lot they have
indeed and we like the trend that we are
on I have to tell you there has been one
slide and one diminishment after another
from the Bredesen camp toward the voters
of Tennessee there's been they've been
referred to as idiots with an expletive
in 1st of idiots by a Brutus and
spokesperson said they weren't worth the
time I you have Hillary of course the
deplorable z' comment and bredesen steam
kind of following back on with that in
their spokesperson mark brown's comments
but here's the thing sean Tennesseans
are pretty specific about what they want
in their next u.s. senator they want a
conservative they want more
constitutional judges they want to keep
their tax cuts and i can guarantee you
this they want that southern border
secured and they're very concerned about
the caravan that is coming through
mexico into our southern border and
every day people are saying marcia we
know you're going to stand with the
president and you're going to stand to
get that wall built and absolutely i am
in it's a pivotal issue in this race you
know I would say Martha Cavanaugh
Caravan a lot of the rhetoric of the
left has been so over the top and the
economy's turned around dramatically are
we better off than we were two years ago
and I'm not talking about the Forgotten
men and women that I talked about in
2016
they're better off we've had the biggest
tax cuts less regulation four million
jobs created eight million fewer people
on poverty and food stamps I like
America succeeding and the border is a
big issue in Arizona
amen Sean I mean I was at a small
business conference today and the
optimism is there because of the
conservative policies we're working with
President Trump in cutting taxes and
rolling back regulations people are
being lifted out of poverty and thanks
to the leadership of Governor Ducey here
Arizona is open for business and we want
to keep going in that direction but
border security is a big issue the two
bases in my district are now going to be
staging areas for the military coming in
a picture so we welcome them arizona's
crazy i go ahead and that literally
thinks it's okay to join the Taliban
john james exactly and you know what i'd
like to see in michigan I would live in
a Detroit
I'd love to see this great city
revitalized instead of talking about
knocking down and tired
neighborhoods to consolidate services
that can happen yes it can absolutely
and you mentioned in your last segment
about people who are coming up from
Central and South America who want the
American Dream who can blame them
but the thing is so do people in
Michigan so do people in Detroit Detroit
has become Jim Crow North when Detroit
is the number one most segregated city
in the in the entire country and Senator
Stabenow has been an elected official
for 43 years been in a position to do
something about it and hasn't we need to
make sure that we bring positive
sustainable change for everyone and
Detroit is where we need to start and we
need to start bringing more jobs back to
Michigan I can do that
Marc sure we give you the last 20
seconds I tell you this is going to be a
great race and I think the more that the
American people and Tennesseans are
looking at what happened to Cavanaugh
what is happening with this caravan
wanting to keep their tax cuts in
thinking about what it would look like
if you had a majority leader Chuck
Schumer and a Speaker Nancy Pelosi
they're rethinking this Shawn I think
that we're going to do very well on
Tuesday November 6 all right thank you
all for being with us and we'll be
watching closely to six nights from
tonight